bonjour à tous hier en fin d'après midi
les sénateurs ont adopté le projet de
loi sur les emprunts toxiques
ces emprunts toxiques ce sont des
crédits qu'au départ avait l'air très
alléchant mais dont les taux est très
variable alors depuis ces taux se sont
emballés ils ont littéralement asphyxié
certaines collectivités certains offices
hlm certains hôpitaux alors comment
sortir de cette situation qui doit payer
alors est ce que ce sont les
collectivités dont certains estiment
avoir été floués est ce que cela doit
être au contraire les banques est ce que
c'est une responsabilité partagée tout
le problème c'est que l'actionnaire
principal de ces établissements de
crédit qui ont proposé ces prêts
structurés et bien c'est l'état et que
le crédit dont on parle représente une
somme colossale 17 milliards d'euros
alors face à cette situation de blocage
ce projet de loi propose une solution de
compromis il propose la création d'un
fonds de soutien aux collectivités doté
de 100 millions d'euros par an et cela
pour 15 ans un fonds qui serait financé
aux deux tiers par les banques est au
tiers par l'état en échange de la
création de ce fonds les collectivités
accepte de régler la facture avec la
possibilité toutefois de négocier des
sorties de ce crédit à taux variable
pour arriver à des crédits à taux fixes
tout de suite donc retour à cette séance
c'était hier après midi au sénat
avant l'article 1er un amendement numéro
qui est présentée par monsieur roquet
oui monsieur le président monsieur min
sur collègues dans sa séance du 6
décembre 2011 la commission d' enquête
parlementaire de l'assemblée nationale
laquelle on fait référence dans nos
débats appelés commissions bartolone
gorges a adopté à l'unanimité un rapport
très instructif sur la réalité les
emprunts structurés souscrits par les
collectivités territoriales et les
autres acteurs du secteur public le
sdiss organismes hlm par exemple
comportant un certain nombre
d'observations et de propositions
parmi les recommandations et
propositions de ce rapport figuraient
entre autres deux propositions à ses
élans essentiel que j'aime me mettre de
rappeler ici la première visait à
interdire le recours à l'emprunt pour
les communes de moins de 10000 habitants
et les établissements publics de moins
de vingt mille habitants s'agissant
d'autres produits que les produits à
taux fixe ou ceux dont le taux variables
étaient établis sur la base 1 à 10
identifiables de la zone euro nous en
avons tous ici une certaine expérience
singulièrement avec la dette hlm qui est
très largement assise sur les variations
du taux de rémunération du livret a
référence aisément identifiable pour
n'importe quel débiteur la seconde
proposition formulée par la commission
denquête tenait tendait à interdire
purement et simplement l'offre de prêts
structurés ou dérivés avec
multiplicateur pour toutes les
collectivités locales
le rapport souligné à ce propos que
l'engagement des finances locales ne
peut se faire qu'en poursuivant à
l'intérêt général présentant un
caractère local et que par voie de
conséquence je cite les produits à effet
de levier classé parmi les produits les
plus risquées présente donc un caractère
spéculatif qui n'apparaît pas compatible
avec l'utilisation des deniers publics à
des fins d'intérêt général fin de
citation pour résumer notre propos on ne
peut donc engager impunément les
ressources publiques pour mener des
opérations de caractère spéculatif qui
au demeurant ne risquent fort de servir
que l'établissement de crédit qui les
auront piloter promu et in fine est
vendu il convient donc que les
évolutions de la législation dans les
mois qui viennent permettent de définir
un nouveau cadre riddick opératoire et
efficaces pour le financement des
collectivités locales
la loi de séparation des activités
bancaires dont nous reparlerons a posé
quelques jalons en la matière mais il ne
il nous apparaît qu'il faut prévoir
également d'autres règles notre
amendement vise à mettre à l'étude la
proposition formulée non sans un certain
bon sens il faut le dire par les membres
de la commission d' enquête
parlementaire de l'assemblée nationale
comprenant entre autres membres éminents
madame fourneyron et monsieur garraud ou
encore le président de l'association des
maires de france monsieur jacques
pélissard nous savons bien que l'article
32 de la loi de séparation peut faire le
compte après avec son décret forte
attendue mais autant se demander s'il ne
conviendrait pas en tout état de cause
de poser ici le principe de
l'interdiction de produits structurés
dont l' usage peut s'apparenter à celui
de ce que certains appellent une bombe à
retardement
changer le paysage financier local ce
qui constitue aujourd'hui et pour
quelques temps encore la raison d'être
de nos débats est une nécessité
économique autant d'ailleurs pour le
secteur bancaire et financier lui-même
que pour l'économie en général tout
simplement parce que le secteur public
local porte encore à ce jour et ce
depuis plusieurs années plus de soixante
dix pour cent de l'investissement public
et qu'il est donc générateur d'emplois
d'activité de croissance et de sortie de
crise allégé la contrainte financière
pesant sur les collectivités locales
c'est donc se donner les moyens de
dépenser mieux en générant emploi et
croissance plutôt qu aventurisme
financiers je vous remercie
monsieur le rapporteur sur cet
amendement numéro 7
de commissions je demande le retrait de
cet amendement s'il enregistre est
défavorable car considère la commission
des finances considèrent qu'ils sont
satisfaits par l'article 32 de la loi de
séparation et de régulation des
activités bancaires et monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le ministre
bien sûr le président le gouvernement
est défavorable à cet amendement le
sénateur si vous ne le retire y est pas
je demanderai de leur rejet il a été dit
que l'article 32 et l'article 34 de la
loi de séparation bancaire répondait
déjà très largement à votre
préoccupation partagée vous avez fait
allusion au projet de décret
d'application que je peux vous dire que
ce décret était actuellement examinée
par le conseil d'état qu'il a déjà été
vue par le comité des finances locales
qui s'est d'ailleurs prononcé
favorablement à l'unanimité
donc je pense que vous êtes
tout à fait rassuré que
d'autre part s'il fallait encore vous
convaincre que la même loi bancaire
donne à l'autorité de contrôle
prudentiel le pouvoir de suspendre ou
d'interdire les activités qu'elle
pourrait estimer dangereuses ou la
commercialisation d'ailleurs de produits
menaçant la stabilité financière telle
est bien le cas donc rejet si cet
amendement n'est pas retirée si monsieur
le ministre
y at il des explications de vote
l'amendement est maintenue je le mets
aux voix qui et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient
il est rejeté
avant l'article 1er un amendement numéro
8 qui est présenté
allez-y ma chère collègue
monsieur le président à national
mes chers collègues on pourrait
évidemment s'étonner de trouver cet
amendement ici mais ce n'est pas là une
question secondaire à nos yeux en effet
comme l'indiquent le projet de loi et
cela nous sommes là c'est nettement
discutable le sens du texte ne couvre si
l'on peut dire que les engagements
souscrits par les personnes morales de
droit public ce qui exclut comme ont
souligné un certain nombre de
spécialistes du droit des personnes
morales de droit privé exerçant des
activités parfois proche de celle menée
par les personnes morales de droit
public pour ne prendre que deux exemples
sous certaines conditions
nous allons voir le fonds de soutien
annoncées récemment intervenir pour les
hôpitaux aux prises avec leurs emprunts
structurés et ce n'est pas un mal
puisqu'il souffre déjà bien souvent de
l'encadrement de l'objectif national de
dépenses d'assurance maladie tandis que
les cliniques privées qui auraient
souscrit le même type de services
financiers n'auront que la bienveillance
de leurs créanciers ou celle de leurs
actionnaires pour faire face au problème
de la même manière les organismes hlm
publique quand bien même on til
relativement peu souscrit d'emprunts
structurés se situe dans le champ
d'intervention des fonds de soutien
tandis que les entreprises sociales pour
l'habitat les sociétés anonymes hlm par
exemple se retrouvent situés hors du
champ d'application du texte là encore
d'autres solutions existent pour faire
face aux problèmes posés et il importe
que nous soyons informés ès qualité de
représentant du peuple français de la
manière dont la question des emprunts
structurés peut être résolu car voyez
vous même si un risque
d'inconstitutionnalité du texte réside
dans la distinction faite entre
personnes morales de droit public et de
droit privé il n'en demeure pas moins
que nous devons aussi savoir si les
établissements de crédit font preuve de
plus ou moins de mansuétude à l'endroit
de lancre de l'an à l'endroit de leur
clientèle selon son statut juridique
c'est bien évidemment la l'objet de ce
rapport demandons-nous par exemple si ce
qu'une collectivités locales confrontées
à une renégociation délicate de ces
emprunts structurés n'arrive pas à
obtenir peut s'avérer plus facile pour
une entreprise privée ce sont ces
informations y compris pour légiférer au
plus près des besoins réels de
financement du secteur public local dont
nous avons besoin qu'ils devraient être
contenues dans le rapport demandé par
cet amendement c'est pour cela que je
vous invite à l'adopter merci même
kuperman monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le président l'amendement
numéro 8 est satisfait par la troisième
partie du même article 32 qui prévoit le
dépôt d'un rapport annuel sur les
emprunts structurés mais évidemment
n'est pas étendue aux personnes morales
de droit privé bien entendu il faudrait
examiner cela ceci étant dit à
l'occasion de cet amendement 8 est en
avance sur l'amendement 13 j'appelle
l'attention du ministre sur le fait que
le rapport que nous attendions n'a pas
été
déposé
merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre
oui le gouvernement d défavorable à cet
amendement pour les mêmes raisons que
celles évoquées par votre rapporteur
j'ajoute que
l'administration n'est pas dotée des
pouvoirs d'investigation nécessaires
pour apporter une information de
précision et de qualité sur les
personnes physiques
ça pourrait être le cas de la cpr qui a
déjà été cité et que votre commission a
tout loisir d'auditionner je pense ou
d'interroger sur ce type de questions
s'agissant du rapport évoqué déjà
plusieurs reprises monsieur rapporteur
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire tout à
l'heure que ce rapport serait remis
avant l'été en confessant un certain
retard par rapport à aux dates qui
aurait pu être de bonnes pratiques et je
veillerai à ce que ce rapport vous soit
remis avant l'été merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission finances
je voulais à partir de l'amendement qui
est en discussion et soulignait que dans
le cadre des travaux effectués pour
notre commission en charge du contrôle
de l'application des lois et un rapport
a récemment été présenté à la commission
des finances monsieur le ministre sur
les textes d'application qui sont encore
attendus notamment à la suite de la loi
de séparation des activités
bancaire et vous venez d'apporter une
réponse mais concernant le rapport que
nous dites vous le gouvernement a
l'intention de déposer à bref délai et
il y a plusieurs autres dispositions
substantielle
issu de la loi de séparation des
activités bancaires et qui pour
l'instant est sont en retard de mise en
oeuvre compte tenu de la nécessité de
publier les textes d'application
et je précise au passage que ceci vaut
pour la délimitation
des des secteurs d'activités au sein
d'un groupe bancaire et vous vous
souvenez certainement fort bien monsieur
le ministre en raison de vos anciennes
fonctions de rapporteur général de la
commission des finances de l'assemblée
nationale que ceci était le coeur même
du texte relatif à la séparation des
activités bancaires et au contrôle des
banques notre commission des finances
bien sûr et très attaché à ce que ce
texte qui avait été ici examiné dans une
ambiance tout à fait constructive et
même quasiment consensuel puisse être
mise en oeuvre le plus tôt possible
ce qui est nécessaire pour une bonne
visibilité de tous les acteurs de la
place financière et bancaire de paris
merci monsieur le président madame
kuperman pour l'explication de vote oui
j'ai entendu les différents arguments
faisant confiance effectivement au
travail de la commission et donc sous
réserve a priori d'une audition de la
cpr par la commission des finances
dans un délai raisonnable nous retirons
cet amendement
merci il est retiré un amendement numéro
13 qui est présenté par madame beaufils
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre chers collègues cet amendement
porte spécifiquement sur l'une des
dispositions clés de la loi de
séparation une régulation des activités
bancaires l'une des promesses essentiel
du candidat françois hollande lors de la
présidentielle de 2012
devenue la loi du 26 juillet 2013
l'article 32 de même que les articles 33
à 35 de cette loi définit les conditions
de développement d'une nouvelle offre de
prêts bancaires aux collectivités
locales suite aux décisions et mesures
d'extinction progressive de dexia et de
ses actifs conséquences de la quasi
faillite de l'établissement sur le fond
d'ailleurs les dispositions concernées
ont qualifié spécifié de la nature du
financement local définissant un
ensemble de paramètres précis pour les
produits bancaires mis sur le marché en
direction des collectivités locales
d'une certaine manière si les
collectivités n'ont pas la qualité de
signature de l'état la loi de séparation
a tout de même consacré la spécificité
de la constitution de leur dette
financière il y a d'ailleurs à cela une
raison principale que nous avons rappelé
lors de la discussion générale c'est
l'obligation
que cette dépense soit inscrite au
budget de la collectivité est tout
établissement de crédit c'est lorsqu'ils
prêtent de l'argent à une collectivité
locale qu'il recevra en échange le
remboursement du capital et des intérêts
fusse t-il assuré par la mobilisation de
l'épargné de ladite collectivité ou
l'augmentation des impositions locales
le projet de décret donc pris en
application de l'article 32 de la loi
paration bancaire vous l'avez dit
monsieur le ministre a été récemment
soumis au comité des finances locales
entre autres dispositions se décrit
propose de mettre en oeuvre des
modalités de plafonnement des taux
d'intérêts associées aux prêts à taux
variable qui fut dirais entre autres
propositions dans le rapport de la
commission bartolone sur le fond
d'ailleurs le projet de décret
représente un certain nombre d'avancées
et il revient quelque peu sur la
banalisation du financement de
l'investissement local qui était la
marque d année de déréglementation
financière et singulièrement de
président de privatisation du crédit
local de france seulement l'article 32
10 mois après la promulgation du texte
est plus ou moins un an après ça les
premières lectures n'a pas encore
véritablement trouver application
le projet de décret n'étant toujours
qu'un projet vous là vous en avez parlé
tout à l'heure bien évidemment mais on a
un petit peu l'impression que quelque
part les difficultés de sortie sont
peut-être lié à la difficulté avec la
profession bancaire qui manifesteraient
quelques réticences à accepter les
termes du décret au seul motif que les
modifications conventionnelle rendue
possible par application de l'article
tente 32 mettrait en question le produit
net bancaire des établissements seraient
de fait regrettable que les intentions
du législateur que nous sommes tous ici
soit mise en cause par un texte
réglementaire dont la portée serait
limitée et n'apporterait que des
modifications cosmétiques aux
obligations contractuelles et
conventionnel des parties donc notre
maman a comme objectif principal une
alerte sur la mise en oeuvre effective
de la loi du 26 juillet 2013 il noie
dont nous souhaiterions éviter qu'elle
ne rejoigne avant peu la longue série
des textes emplis de bonnes intentions
mais sans lendemain merci même beau fils
mme sur à porter
monsieur le président donc 7 cet
amendement exprimé une préoccupation
légitime voilà je ne suis pas sûr que la
publication d'un rapport soit l'élément
naturel pour pouvoir accélérer la sortie
d'un décret d'application
donc je demanderai leur retrait de cet
amendement mais si monsieur le ministre
vous pouviez réitéré à ce que vous avez
dit précédemment sur le décret
d'application je pense que ça pourrait
rassurer nous nos collègues l'ensemble
du sénat est donc peut-être amené le
retrait de cet amendement
merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre
oui madame la sénatrice je voudrais
profiter de votre amendement pour
répondre aussi aux présidents marini qui
m'interpelle sur les textes qui
manquerait encore pour appliquer la loi
qui a été adopté un certain consensus
comme le président le rappela l'instant
à ma connaissance
il manque un arrêté et un décret
pour que cette loi soit parfaitement
dans les délais qui ont été prescrits le
décret a été signé par monsieur sapin me
dit on et l'arrêté qui manque sera fait
avant le 1er juillet prochain la
l'engagement que je peux prendre ici
devant la représentation nationale
concernant
ce qui est évoqué
madame j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
m'exprimer sur le fait que
le le texte que vous évoquez a déjà été
adoptée vu par le comité des finances
locales que le conseil d'état est
actuellement en train de l'examiner je
pense qu'il fera lui aussi opérationnel
à la fin de cet été c'est pourquoi je
pense que il y aurait au lieu de retirer
votre amendement faute de quoi je
demanderai au sénat de le rejeter
merci monsieur le ministre madame
beaufils pour explication de vote oui
monsieur
le ministre vient nous apporter un peu
plus de précision puisqu'il nous dit que
dans le cadre des applications un décret
a été signé par monsieur sapin ça veut
dire qu'on est en train d'avancé puisque
n'est pas longtemps que monsieur sapin
est arrivé en responsabilité dans ce
ministère donc ça veut dire que c'est
tout neuf donc nous avions raison de
nous interroger sur la mise en oeuvre
nous allons vous donner acte de cette
évolution positive et nous allons
retirer cet amendement
merci mme beaufils il est retiré un
amendement numéro 9 qui est présenté
par mme beaufils
oui la discussion excusez moi monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre chers
collègues la discussion générale a
largement montré que pour certains nos
collègues le conflit des prêts
structurés est un peu comme un divorce à
torts partagés entre les collectivités
territoriales et les établissements de
crédit ce qui a d'ailleurs conduit assez
étrangement à concevoir un fonds de
soutien
dont l'intervention était en quelque
sorte plafonné à une partie de
l'indemnité de remboursement anticipé
que les collectivités doivent acquitter
à raison de la résolution de leur
situation propre
pour notre part nous sommes plutôt
enclin à penser comme l'avait souligné
la commission bartolone gorgue que la
responsabilité des établissements de
crédit est particulièrement importante
eu égard entre autres aux obligations
des collectivités en matière de dépenses
il est évident que tirant parti de la
faible connaissance présumés des arcanes
de la finance par les élus locaux et les
techniciens et fonctionnaires dont ils
disposent dans leur équipe les
établissements de crédit et
singulièrement dexia ont mené des
politiques commerciales agressives
au demeurant s'il convenait de
rechercher une preuve nous la
trouverions probablement dans l'encours
des prêts structurés dans le bilan de
l'établissement regard de l'encours de
même type figurant au bilan des autres
établissements de crédit notre collègue
député dominique baert élus du nord et
désormais vice président aux finances de
lille métropole l'avait d'ailleurs
souligné dans sa contribution
personnelle au rapport de la commission
denquête en indiquant je vais citer
quelques éléments la stratégie des
banques mobilisés à commercialiser ses
produits opaques
leur défaut d'information d' alerte et
de conseil enfin la vente de produits
spéculatifs proscrite par la circulaire
de 92
tout cela est manifeste de la part des
banques et ils précisaient les banques
ont présenté les produits de manière
tellement opaque que la question se pose
de leurs responsabilités pour tromperie
il disait également la symétrie de
compétences spécialisées sur les
finances de marchés entre les services
des collectivités locales et les banques
créent un déséquilibre des informations
déséquilibre des compétences entre d'une
part des établissements banques au fait
des données financières pointus et des
modèles mathématiques complexes et des
collectivités qui au mieux dispose d'une
équipe administrative
formé à la gestion des produits simples
et qui surtout manque ça c'est moi
qu'ils ajoutent d'accompagnement
véritablement par
la structure de l'état qui pourrait leur
apporter des aides ou la perception ou
la préfecture mais on voit bien que là
non plus les collectivités n'ont pas pu
bénéficier
d'accompagnement nécessaires à assumer
leurs responsabilités face à des
domaines qu'elles ne peuvent pas
maîtriser en interne par des personnels
véritablement faut être formés à cet
effet donc c'est pourquoi nous vous
avons proposé
cet amendement qui nous permettrait de
faire en sorte que le fonds de soutien
tienne mieux compte de cette réalité en
particulier pour les plus petites
communes merci même office monsieur
rapporteur
merci merci monsieur le président que
cet amendement s'il était adopté
modifierait l'équilibré qui a été trouvé
en loi de finances équilibre je
l'appelle entre d'une part
responsabilité des collectivités
territoriales et d'autre part l'aide
apportée à leur sortie de la difficulté
c'est là dessus que le taux de 45%
c'était s'était fixé j'ajoute en plus
que si on augmente ce taux pour les uns
c'est vrai le diminuer pour les autres
donc mon avis défavorable merci monsieur
rapporteur monsieur le ministre
oui merci sur le président gouvernement
est du même avis que le rapporteur je
crois que pour bien comprendre il faut
se souvenir de l'origine de ce
de ce plafond de 45%
au départ qu'il n'y avait pas de plafond
dans la loi dans la loi initiale et
certains ont dit mais s'il n'y a pas de
plafond
le fait qu'ils aient notamment des
collectivités d'importance qui pourrait
faire appel au fond on va priver
mécaniquement les plus petites d'entre
elles de pouvoir en bénéficier faute de
crédits disponibles et donc
c'était une initiative parlementaire
personnel que ce plafond de 45 % était
introduit c'est de façon justement à
faire le contraire de ce que vous
craignez c'est à dire de permettre aux
plus petits des collectivités de trouver
place dans un fonds dont tout le monde a
reconnu on peut dire on peut le gérer le
juge et de différentes façons dont tout
le monde a reconnu qu'il ne couvrait pas
l'intégralité des charges qui vont
rester aux collectivités territoriales
loin s'en faut peut-être certains diront
trop loin s'en faut donc c'est vrai que
c'est l' équilibre qui a été retenu sur
45 cents et sur les critères je vous
rappelle qu'il prenne en compte de par
la loi
la capacité de désendettement de la
collectivité
mesuré par le rapport entre l'encours de
la dette et l'épargné brute ce qui
permet de prendre en compte la
difficulté auquel pourrait se trouver
face auquel pourraient se trouver les
collectivités deuxième vol potentiel
financier de la collectivité il ya donc
bien une approche différenciée qui est
prévue mme paraît pas opportun de
retenue de retenir votre amendement s'il
était maintenu je demanderai au sénat de
le rejeter merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur vincent pour explication de
vote
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
chers collègues je voulais d'abord
m'excuser vous demander de bien vouloir
m'excuser puisque je m'étais inscrit
pour la discussion générale et je n'ai
malheureusement pas pu y participer pour
des raisons personnelles je voudrais
rejoindre l'avis de monsieur le
rapporteur et de monsieur le ministre
sur
sur cet amendement en important sur et
sur leurs positions en apportant en
apportant un élément d'explication
complémentaires qui peut être utile je
crois pour avancer enfin qu'il pourrait
l'être pour avancer sur ce dossier
lorsque ce fonds de soutien a été
négocié pour y avoir participé du côté
des collectivités territoriales il était
acquis dans l'esprit de tous que c'était
une contribution d'un fonds de soutien
qui venait parachever un accord un pré
accord transactionnel en quelque sorte
entre la banque qui avait placé les
produits et les collectivités cela
signifiait dans mon esprit mais je crois
dans l'esprit de tous que si le fonds
peut intervenir jusqu'à 45% ça ne
signifie pas qu'il reste forcément à
charge des collectivités 55
car dans l'accord transactionnel il est
logique de prévoir une participation de
la banque c'est une affaire à discuter
évidemment selon les cas mais ça peut
être 10 20 parfois 30% pour avoir moi
même à l'époque à saint etienne obtenu
de telles négociations de tels efforts
du secteur bancaire on voit bien que on
peut arriver raisonnablement avec ces
chiffres à une partage d un partage des
charges qui permet une sortie acceptable
pour tous je le souligne pour dire
immédiatement que mon inquiétude
puisque ça c'est un schéma qui peut
marquer un marché qui pourra marcher en
d'autant plus avec le fonds de soutien
qui a marché sans fonds de soutien qui
pourra marché d'autant plus avec fonds
de soutien mon inquiétude c'est l'effort
que pourra faire là ce fils
puisque l'as fils et la banque l'une des
banques les plus
impliqués aujourd'hui dans le règlement
final de cette affaire-là jusqu'à
présent l'attitude des dirigeants de
l'asf il est donc deux états a derrière
évidemment a toujours été extrêmement
durs
alors presque la plus dure donc moi je
forme le voeu tout en
considérant que ce rapport 45 55 et est
acceptable et donc en n'approuvant pas
cet amendement je forme lui et je pense
que c'est très important pour que la sfi
les l'état fasse en sorte que dans les
d'accord transactionnel qui vont pouvoir
être discuté je pense qu'il faut qu'il
soit discuté maintenant très rapidement
avec la mise en oeuvre du fonds de
soutien pour sortir de cette affaire va
permettre à l'as fils d'apporter sa
contribution
et si l'état doit faire un effort en
amont je pense que il gagnera au final
en favorisant un maximum d' accord
impliquant la sfic plutôt plutôt qu'en
allant jusqu'à des contentieux
interminable voilà mon point de vue
merci monsieur vincent
madame beaufils
oui j'ai bien entendu les robes de
monsieur le ministre et les compléments
qu'il a apportée concernant les
conditions dans lesquelles
le fonds peut être accordée par rapport
à la situation mais nous avions
également complétée d'une autre
protection pour passer à 55 % c'était
le niveau des indemnités par rapport aux
recettes de fonctionnement des
collectivités et ce à partir d'exemples
locaux qui dont on sent qu'il ne trouve
pas résolution et moi je suis quand même
assez inquiètes de voir les conditions
dans lesquelles actuellement l'asf il
est en train de renégocier avec un
certain nombre de collectivités et où
j'estime que les indemnités de
renégociation de ces prêts sont beaucoup
trop élevés par rapport aux capacités
des collectivités concernées et c'est ce
que je disais un petit peu dans
l'intervention général tout à l'heure on
a à la fois une demande d'indemnité très
très lourde et en même temps on est à la
période où les collectivités vont avoir
de moins en moins de capacité de pouvoir
répondre à ces remboursements très lourd
qui leur sont demandés pour sortir de
ces emprunts structurés donc on voit
bien que ce serait quand même assez
important aujourd'hui de continuer à
regarder véritablement comme en impact
les collectivités territoriales parce
que certaines se sont retrouvés et vont
se retrouver pour les nouvelles qui
négocient dans des situations proches de
la faillite financière faut quand même
qu'on regarde les choses avec réalisme
nous maintiendrons donc notre amendement
il sera rejeté mais
je pense que c'est important
merci même beau fils je ne vois plus
d'explications de vote donc je vais le
mettre aux voix qui et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient
il n'est pas adopté un amendement numéro
10 qui est présentée par monsieur
bloqués
oui monsieur le président monsieur
ministre chers collègues cet amendement
complément naturellement celui que nous
venons de défendre sur l'intervention du
fonds de soutien et participe par
ailleurs de notre position de principe
sur le sujet
dans les faits nous souhaitons accroître
les ressources du fonds de soutien par
une augmentation de la contribution des
établissements de crédit il y va
d'ailleurs en cette matière de l'intérêt
bien compris des finances publiques
accroître la contribution du secteur
financier à la résolution des problèmes
que les agissements de dexia et de
quelques autres établissements ont créé
n'est pas scandaleux c'est à nos yeux
tout à fait logique on nous objectera
peut-être que cela revient en portant à
600 millions d'euros l'apport des
établissements de crédit au fonds de
soutien a demandé aux établissements nos
fautif de payer pour les mauvais élèves
de la classe mais mes chers collègues le
principe des mécanismes de solidarité
telle que définie par exemple dans le
cadre de l'union bancaire ne
participe-t-il pas de là cette même
responsabilité collective des secteurs
financier en cas de défaillance de l'un
d'entre eux et la mutualisation des
ressources ainsi mise en oeuvre de nos
fonds dans le fonds de soutien n'est pas
plus scandaleuse que celle qui préside à
la constitution progressive du fonds
créé dans le cadre de l'union bancaire
autre observation parfaitement essentiel
et qui procède de notre interprétation
de la crise des subprimes nord
américains entre autres qu'on le veuille
ou non les activités de l'ensemble des
établissements de crédit sont un terreau
agissante systémique et quand dexia
attend d'une collectivité locale le
remboursement d'un emprunt en capital et
en intérêts un autre établissement de
crédit sollicité pour apporter les fonds
levés par dexia attend lui aussi le
retour des sommes concernées il n'est
d'ailleurs pas interdit de penser qu'à
un contrat de swap notionnels proposé
par dexia à ses débiteurs net était en
amont revendus par les propres
créanciers de dexia et diffuser encore à
d'autres notamment par le biais d'une
opération devenue assez banal de
titrisation il ya donc une solidarité
systémique clairement établie entre
dexia la plus exposée des banques ayant
distribué les emprunts structurés et les
autres établissements de crédit par
parallélisme des formes nous ne pouvons
donc que vous proposez l'expression la
plus parfaite de cette solidarité de
place solidarité systémique toute autre
considération et notamment l'absence de
relèvement de la contribution des
banques au règlement de la situation
créée reviendrait selon nous comme le
texte nous y amène de gré ou de force a
rajouté à l'aministie bancaire le
scandale de la déresponsabilisation pure
et simple des acteurs on rappellera
parlons un peu chiffres pour souligner
le poids terrible de l'augmentation que
nous préconisons que 0 0 39% des fonds
propres exigés les établissements de
crédit suffirait à recueillir 50
millions d'euros et que par conséquent
moins d'un demi point de ses fonds
propres exigés suffiront à alimenter le
fonds au niveau où nous sous l'eau et
nous le souhaitons aux dernières
nouvelles d'ailleurs la santé économique
de notre établissement bancaire peut
faire rêver un article d'un grand
quotidien du soir paru le 5 février
dernier faisait apparaître les chiffres
des bénéfices réalisés par les deux
premières banques françaises la première
d'entre elles un chiffre assez
impressionnant de 4 milliards huit cent
trente millions d'euros et le deuxième 2
2 milliards d'euros donc dans notre
esprit vous le voyez bien pas de
dogmatisme idéologique de notre part
mais soutien à une solution pragmatique
et réaliste puisque c'est un mot très en
vogue par les temps qui courent je
remercie monsieur bouquet monsieur le
rapporteur
monsieur le président donc notre
collègue par avance avant c'est un des
arguments que je vais reprendre qui est
que effectivement peut pas demander à
des banques qui n'ont pas de délivrer de
de prêts toxiques d'aller
au delà de ce que nous considérons comme
une solidarité là je veux dire on
franchit un seuil extrêmement important
donc chacun évidemment peut l'apprécier
jeunes l'apprécient pas de la même façon
que que notre collègue bloqué et un
deuxième sujet c'est que dans cet
amendement il est indiqué que les sommes
figurant au paragraphe 3 de l'article 32
qui seraient prises pour augmenter fin
l'augmentation de la taxe systémique il
n'y aurait pas de ce ne serait pas
déductible de l'impôt sur les sociétés
ce qui porterait la contribution du
secteur bancaire n'ont pas à 600
millions d'euros mais 1,2 milliard par
an ce qui me semble dans les
circonstances actuelles exagéré donc je
donne envie des favoris mais rssi
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre
le gouvernement partage là encore l'avis
du rapporteur qui a opportunément
rappelé que save était d'ailleurs un
point de débat un sur le fait que le
fonds soit constitué par un apport de
l'ensemble du secteur bancaire ce par le
biais de la taxe ou systémique alors
même si ça vient d'être dit que
certaines n'avaient pas commercialisé de
produits toxiques nous avons considéré
qu'il devait y avoir une
solidarité entre les établissements
financiers ne serait ce que parce que le
risque sur l'important risque systémique
sur l'ensemble du dispositif et nous
sommes arrivés à ce point
j'ajoute que le principe de la parité
entre les banques et l'état a été à peu
près respectées enfin et même respecté
par ses tours tout cas sur la part par
systémique le reste c'est là ce filet
les contributions volontaires donc je
crois qu'il n'y a pas lieu de modifier
ce point
en tout cas pas sur ce motif ans
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
collombat pour explication de vote
oui cet amendement nous conduit à
revenir sur le problème des
responsabilités
on aura l'occasion d'en reparler tout à
leurs
responsables qui ceux qui ont laissé
installer ce système
ce système qui se trouvent à la merci
d'un jugement d'un tg
les gouvernements qui se sont succédé
depuis une trentaine d'années dans ce
beau pays
responsables aussi peut-être le ceux qui
sont chargés du contrôle de légalité
enfin tout le monde sait bien que on est
suffisamment embêté pour les 5e chiffres
après la virgule on pourrait peut-être
regarder les chiffres avant la virgule
puis responsable
les banques et les collectivités
certes
mais pas à 50 pour sa
part
parce que quand on regarde jules le
rapport de la cour des comptes de 2011
alors effectivement on a pu épingler
successeur les prédécesseurs de notre
collègue qui entre deux entre deux tours
d'élections municipales ont fait du
trapèze et cetera pour sauver la face
mais ça c'est l'arbre qui cache la forêt
la cour des comptes le dis clairement je
donnerai tout à l'heure des citations ce
sera l'occasion d'y revenir
donc il faudrait quand même savoir où tu
es alors c'est quand même extrêmement
donc sur rien d'étonnant à ce que on
leur demande quand même de participer
alors je trouve ce discours sur la
solidarité on ferait payer les pots
malheureux qui n'aurait rien fait quand
même un petit peu étonnant parce que
comme l'a dit notre collègue bloquer
tout ça ça fait système et si ça faisait
pas système n'y aurait pas de risque
systémique et s'il n'y avait pas de
risque systémique est bon on ne serait
pas là aujourd'hui
c'est tout donc qu'est ce que ça a de
scandaleux qu'on demande quand même au
système bancaire qui soi-disant serait
en péril si nous ne votions pas parce
que c'est ça si on vote pas le
raisonnement si on vote pas la loi
d'aujourd'hui nous risquons de faire
chuter si l'enfer et ses terrasses qui
peut rester de dexia donc l'ensemble du
système y compris ceux que vous défendez
qui seraient des pauvres malheureux mis
à contribution
alors franchement je trouve
l'argumentation un petit peu légère et
c'est pour ça que je voudrais cet
amendement
merci
monsieur le ministre
je vais répondre à l' intervention
précédente
l'argumentation du gouvernement n'est
pas de dire qu'il s'agit de protéger
et de se prémunir le système bancaire
d'un risque systémique
non non ce sénateur si vous permettez
peut peut-être parfois un peu mieux que
vous transcrire la pensée du
gouvernement l'avancé du gouvernement
est de protéger les intérêts de l'état
voilà on les intérêts de l'état c'est
que en cas de défaillance la suit lé
il y à un risque que c'est que nous
évaluions
autour de 17 milliards d'euros pour
l'état voilà j'ai pas de protéger qui
que ce soit la suite c'est pas un ovni
venu d'ailleurs l'asf il est garanti pas
75%
participation directe de l'état et sur
le reste par un engagement de l'état à
couvrir la caisse des dépôts et la
banque postale
donc sous le risque c'est le budget de
l'état qui le porte
monsieur vincent
oui sur cet amendement
on retrouve tout de même derrière
effectivement la question du jugement
sur les responsabilités si je n'étais
pas présent pour la discussion générale
j'en ai eu un résumé duquel il ressort
que il y à un large consensus pour dire
que la responsabilité est partagée entre
les banques et des collectivités
territoriales en tout cas c'est le
résumé qui m'en a été fait et qui je
crois est et fidèle moi ça n'a jamais
été mon point de vue et je reste à titre
personnel
absolument convaincu de la
responsabilité majeure parce que c'était
les sachants dans cette affaire-là par
rapport aux autres des banques et du
système financier
donc je reste personnellement sur cette
position ce qui m'ennuie dans cet
amendement c'est que puisque j'avais
déposé le même ou à peu près il ya
quelques quelques mois c'est que il
revient il reviendrait en fait à
rediscuter du fonds de soutien qui a
déjà été actée à 100 millions d'euros
sur sur 15 ans qui a un décret
d'application et qui doit entrer en
application le plus vite possible pour
être très concrètement utile aux
collectivités territoriales donc je ne
vote pas cet amendement par pragmatisme
mais sur le fond et sur le fond de
l'analyse je rejoins et je pense
toujours que les banques ont une
responsabilité primordiale et qu'il n'ya
il n'y aurait rien de scandaleux alors
peut-être faudra-t-il rajouter au fonds
de soutien dans un an ou deux dans ce
cas là il faudra revenir à mon sens dans
cette direction merci monsieur vincent
madame beaufils
oui je crois que je ne partage pas ce
que disait monsieur le ministre tout à
l'heure je comprends bien que
aujourd'hui la responsabilité de l'état
est engagée parce que là s'il a été mise
en place dans les conditions que l'on
connaît mais il me semble que c'est bien
le système bancaire c'est pour ça que
j'ai rappelé l'histoire tout à l'heure
c'est le système bancaire dans sa
conception qui est notre véritable
problème et c'est le fait que l'on ait
mis les collectivités dans l'obligation
d'aller se financer sur le marché
financier et la façon dont les banques
ont décidé d'y répondre et d'apporter de
construire la réponse tout ensemble qui
amène à la situation que l'on connaît
aujourd'hui
donc les solliciter plus pour qu'elle
réponde mieux à la crise dans laquelle
on a mis les collectivités à cause de ce
système et me paraît complètement
légitime non pas pour rendre
l'état
en plus mettre l'état en plus grande
difficulté mais bien au contraire pour
apporter une alimentation qui
permettrait de mieux répondre à la
fragilité dans laquelle sont les
collectivités aujourd'hui dans les rues
négociations qui sont menées y compris
avec l'aps il donc c'est pourquoi notre
amendement nous semblait pertinent
merci même office plus d'explications de
vote je vais le mettre aux voix
et pour cet amendement numéro 10
qui et contre
qui s'abstient
il n'est pas adoptée à l'article 1er une
demande de parole de monsieur coulombe a
su que l'on bat
le président monsieur le ministre chers
collègues
pour voir de traiter donc de l'objet
spécifique de ce projet de loi ce que je
ferai avec les amendements que j'ai
déposé je voudrais quand même rappeler
que si nous en sommes encore à coller
des rustines sur dexia
la fatalité n'y est pour rien mais que
c'est uniquement la conséquence d'une
politique qui a été menée
opiniâtrement par tous les gouvernements
qui se sont succédé depuis une trentaine
d'années
dont l'objectif c'était de rendre les
marchés libres de la location de la
ressource financière et donc maîtres de
l'économie
alors quand on applique ça au système de
financement des collectivités
territoriales du secteur public cette
modernisation
avisé arrêt s'est résumée à remplacer un
système public et parapublic et six sur
l'épargné sur des circuits spécialisés
organisés autour de la caisse des dépôts
et consignations le remplacer par un
système à 6 sur l'appel généralisé aux
marchés financiers totalement privée
c'était la mutation tout le système cdc
qui a abouti à la cas depuis donc à
dexia tout ça au nom de l'optimisation
de l'allocation des ressources du
moindre coût et de l'efficacité
l'ascension de la maison dexia piloté
par l'état et la caisse des dépôts puis
sa chute sont le produit de ce processus
le problème c'est que on ne semble pas
avoir tiré les leçons de cette de cette
chute puisque crise ou pas financière
sociale et maintenant politique eh bien
on en est toujours au même point ap
devoir risquer une crise systémique
contrairement à ce qu'on a pu nous dire
là la proposition de là le projet de loi
sur la séparation des activités
bancaires bancaire n'apportera pas de
solution au problème
alors ce qui frappe dans cette affaire
c'est le temps qu'on a mis
à réagir à cette situation de
fragilisation global
parce que tout ça
tout ça c'est produit exotique ils ont
été créés dans les années 90
ça a marché
apparemment très très bien pendant un
certain nombre d'années et puis à partir
des années 2005 on commence à réaliser
que comme disent
comme disent les les suisses il ya le
feu au lac un article célèbre un article
célèbre de michel klopfer en 2007
parlait ça a été évoqué tout à l'heure
par mon collègue bocquet de bombes à
retardement
mais tout ça a continué
2008 je rappelle ça a été la
l'intervention massive de l'état
français de l'état belge et de l'état
luxembourgeois pour sauver dexia de la
faillite et là on a pu découvrir quelle
était l'étendue des dégâts
mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé bah pas
grand chose pas grand chose on a nommé
on a nommé un médiateur en la personne
d'éric dislaire auquel on doit la mise
en place donc d'une d'une charte de
bonne conduite entre les collectivités
et les banques mais
rien de rien de contraignant le problème
était censé se régler tout seul il
faudra attendre la conclusion judiciaire
des conflits en cours pour que l'état
commence à bouger
d'abord à pas comptés et puis maintenant
apparemment en procédure accélérée
vous fais pas je vous fais le détail des
je fais pas le détail des étapes
donc ça a été
d'abord donc la mise en place d'un fonds
à 50 à 50 millions d'euros qui a été
porté à l'autre finances d'après à 100
millions d'euros la censure du conseil
constitutionnel est maintenant une
nouvelle loi pour revenir sur les
décisions de justice
résultats résultat est bien haut lieu le
système est toujours aussi exposé que
l'ancien haut risque de deux crises
systémiques
parce que et c'est un point sur lequel
je voudrais je voudrais insister
quand on a mis en place sur les ruines
de deixa de dexia un nouveau système de
financement des collectivités
territoriales qu'est-ce qu'on n'a pas
trouvé de mieux de faire c'est
d'installer au coeur du système
les emprunts toxiques les bombes à
retardement
hérité de dexia sa a été évoqué tout à
l'heure à propos de la technique qui
aurait peut-être été préférable d'une
banque de de compte elle même mais
on a construit un système qui est de
financement des collectivités
territoriales qui est aussi vulnérable à
la crise que l'ancien alors si on trouve
que c'est vraiment extraordinaire comme
comme manière de faire moi c'est pas du
tout mon avis alors devant l'inertie on
attendait donc que les banques que les
banques négocient l ont pas voulu
négocier en tout cas les conditions
acceptables et bien devant ce refus eh
bien il ya eu donc c'est
c'est
ce recours donc à ce recours donc au
secours pardon rouge au juge qui lui a
donné donc eu des décisions qui ne n'ont
pas convenu ne conviennent pas
apparemment au gouvernement donc voilà
le problème on est là parce que jusque
on a trop tardé à agir est ce que je
crains est bien c'est que on continue à
tergiverser parce que le risque il est
toujours là et c'est un risque
véritablement de faillite du dispositif
si monsieur combat je suis saisi de deux
amendements identiques à l'article 1er
un amendement numéro un qui est présenté
par vous monsieur collomb bas
être le plus clair possible
je dirais que quatre ensemble de raisons
pour moi milite en faveur de la
suppression de cet article comme
d'ailleurs de l'article 2 de l'article 2
et autant dire d'ailleurs pour moi du
projet de loi
premièrement il vise à modifier la
législation
suite à des décisions de justice qui ne
conviennent ni au gouvernement ni aux
banques alors même que des recours ont
été formées sur la base de la
législation existence et existantes
pardon et ne sont pas encore passés en
forme de chose jugée les effets de la
loi sont donc rétroactif
on s'attendrait plutôt à trouver ce type
de pratique dans d'autres états que tu
en france
deuxièmement cette mauvaise manière
envers la justice est aussi un coup bas
je pense porter aux collectivités et aux
organismes publics qui se trouvent ainsi
privés en plein contentieux de leur
principal argument face à des banques
qui ont tout intérêt à gagner du temps
alors on nous a dit j'ai entendu mais
non pour continuer elles pourront
continuer à aller en justice a demandé à
demander réparation etc sauf que un des
arguments essentiels et majeure qui
pourrait leur donner permettre de leur
donner raison et bien aura aura disparu
alors
là cette année c'est un c'est un
argument moi qui me paraît fondamental
si on ne peut pas régler les problèmes
réels que rencontrent l'état sur le dos
des collectivités en leur en leur en
leur prise en les privant d'un argument
essentiel dans leur recours devant
devant les tribunaux
en plus dans ce cas là on constate qu'il
y a qu il y a eu d'autres injustices
c'est que sont traités de la même façon
à la fois ceux qui étaient responsables
qui se sont mis dans le pétrin on l'a
évoqué tout à l'heure et ceux qui ont
été abusés par la banque par défaut par
défaut de conseil ou parfois par une
présentation pour le moins biaisée donc
de la situation et troisième point c'est
que
si le but avoué de ce projet de loi
c'est de pousser à une renégociation à
sortir de ce conflit je pense que ça
n'est pas en
désarmant quasiment totalement l'une des
parties qu'on va y parvenir et tout
ailleurs tout à l'heure il ya eu une
remarque tout à fait tout à fait
pertinente on le retrouve dans le dans
le rapport de la commission des finances
de l'assemblée nationale c'est qu'il
semblerait que les autres banques que
dexia qui n'ont pas été sauvé par l'état
ont été moins
dur dans leurs négociations que dexia ou
à ce fils elle même donc moi cela me
semble quelque chose de tout à fait de
tout à fait irrecevable donc c'est pour
le pourquoi donc du dépôt de cet
amendement monsieur coulombe à un
amendement ne 11 c'est madame beaufils
le défend oui monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre chers collègues cet
article premier présente toutes les
caractéristiques d'un simple article de
validation législative avec les défauts
inhérents à l'exercice
serait d'ailleurs en la matière sans
doute trop long de rappeler la
jurisprudence du juge constitutionnel en
la matière les articles de validation
s'attirant assez souvent les foudres de
celui ci quel que soit le texte concerné
la liste est longue mais il convient
tout de même de revenir quelques
instants sur les considérants de la
décision qui avait censuré l'article 92
de la loi de finances je l' ai dit tout
à l'heure dans mon intervention général
je crois que les éléments qui existaient
pour cette censure et cet article 92
existe aussi pour ce texte de loi je
cite les considérants 76 et 77
considérant qu'aux termes de l'article
16 de la déclaration de 1789
toute société dans laquelle la garantie
des droits n'est pas assurée ni la
séparation des pouvoirs déterminée n'a
point de te consiste de constitution que
si le législateur pour modifier
rétroactivement une règle de droit ou
valider un acte administratif ou de
droit privé c'est à la condition de
poursuivre un but d'intérêt général
suffisant
et de respecter tant les décisions de
justice ayant force de chose jugée que
le principe de non réac trop
rétroactivité des peines et des
sanctions qu en outre l'acte modifier ou
valider ne doit méconnaître aucune règle
ni aucun principe de valeur
constitutionnelle
sauf à ce que le but d'intérêt général
visé soit lui-même de valeur
constitutionnelle
qu'enfin la portée de la modification de
la validation doit être strictement
définies et le 77 considérant que
l'article l 313 2 du code de la
consommation dispose que le taux
effectif global déterminé comme il est
dit à l'article 311 1
doit être mentionné dans tout écrit
constatant un contrat de prêt régi par
ce même article que la mention du taux
effectif global dans le contrat de prêt
constitue un élément essentiel de
l'information des emprunteurs qu'ils
résultent de la jurisprudence constante
de la cour de cassation que l'exigence
d'un écrits mentionnant le taux effectif
global est une condition de la validité
de la stipulation d'intérêt et qu'en
l'absence de stipulations
conventionnelles d'intérêt il convient
de faire application du taux légal à
compter du prêt donc voilà les citations
de ces deux éléments
de tels considérant aurait avait suffi
au conseil constitutionnel pour censurer
l'article 92 et en l'espèce c'est
paragraphe 2 et 3 et je dois relever que
ce le garde pleine valeur pour ce qui
nous intéresse ici nous sommes en
présence d'un article qui fait d'un cas
d'espèce c'était celui du dossier
premier en tout cas de seine-saint-denis
avec dexia un dispositif général ou
plutôt tente d'empêcher l'éventuelle
généralisation
on peut se demander où est l'intérêt
général puisque c'est en effet une des
questions qui est venu dans le rapport
qui a été présenté par jean germain
deviendrait-il incompatible à celui des
habitants de la seine-saint-denis en
premier mais aussi de tous ceux qui
toutes les communes et départements qui
sont concernés dont les impôts locaux
pourrait ainsi croître du poids des
remboursements de la dette structurée
devrait-il s'opposer à l'intérêt des
autres localités confronté donc à ces
mêmes difficultés financières l'intérêt
général se résumerait-il à assurer
l'équilibré des finances de l'état dans
le cadre de nos engagements
et assurer l'extension en bon ordre de
dexia et ne devrait-il pas se préoccuper
aussi de l'intérêt général des
collectivités territoriales qui assure
quand même une responsabilité vis-à-vis
de la masse de la population dans notre
pays nous avons donc pour notre part une
autre conception de cet intérêt général
c'est pourquoi nous pensons que nous ne
pouvons pas adopter cet article 1er de
la loi et que nous vous en proposons la
suppression merci monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le président oui j'ai
indiqué tout à l'heure que le vote d'une
loi de validation était un acte grave
évidemment puisque
ça met en oeuvre le principe de non
rétroactivité des lois et on sait que
normalement les lois ne dispose que pour
l'avenir sauf
loi de validation et que autant la loi
pénale ne peut être rétroactive que si
elle la corne d des conditions plus
favorables
le principe de la rétroactivité
en matière civile est un principe qui
est accepté et depuis longtemps qu'il
n'entame pas le principe de la
séparation entre le pouvoir judiciaire
et le pouvoir législatif mais qu'
évidemment il y à des bornes vous avez
rappelé madame beau fils qui sont à la
fois le contrôle du juge constitutionnel
et d'autre part le contrôle de la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme et en
ce qui concerne le juge constitutionnel
l'indiqué que ça ne pouvait être le cas
que s'il y avait dans un premier temps
injuste intérêt général et maintenant il
y ajouter depuis deux mois une condition
plus grave puisqu'il demande qu'il y ait
un motif d'intérêt général impériaux
voilà le parvenir vous expliquer tout à
l'heure la commission des finances
considéré qu'il y avait que 17 milliards
d'euros de risque était un intérêt
général impérieux c'est
ce que j'ai indiqué tout à l'heure donc
ne suis pas d'accord avec cette cette
présentation des choses qui sont faites
deuxièmement
oui je pense et on en verra certainement
l'application que les les collectivités
territoriales conserve après cette
validation législative la possibilité
d'introduire des instances judiciaires
elles ne peuvent plus le faire sur la
base uniquement de l'absence du tfg ont
dû côté irrégulier du thé aux jets mais
peuvent le faire sur tous les autres
surtout les autres motifs donc
évidemment vous en doutez l'avis de la
commission des finances est défavorable
à ces amendements
si monsieur rapporteur monsieur ministre
oui plus merci au président très
brillamment puisque l'analyse juridique
aux constitutionnel de votre rapporteur
est éloquente
le gouvernement dans ce texte a tiré les
enseignements du jugement que vous avez
rappelé
dont vous avez lu ainsi nombre
d'extraits et nous considérons que tous
les enseignements et été tirée c'est à
dire que je vous l'avais dit aussi vous
même les collectivités pourront toujours
ester sur d'autres motifs qui sont des
motifs d'absence
manifeste de
respect de la prudence nécessaire la
formule m'échappe à cet instant ou tout
autre motif mais plus sur l'absence de
du tfg dont on a d'ailleurs rappelé
aussi quelle a été l'origine
et qui n'est pas forcément en rapport
avec les contrats
vague dont il s'agit ici jamais de
gaieté de coeur si j'ose dire que
le parlement je crois procède à des
validations juridique mais nous estimons
que 17 milliards de risques financiers
encore une fois estimé certains pensent
que c'est moi mais d'autres je pense que
c'est plus
à c'est quand même un risque c'est un
risque très important sur l' équilibre
sans parler de ce qui a été dit déjà sur
le risque systémique sur l'ensemble du
secteur où les difficultés je pas
répondu tout à l'heure à quelques
interprétations sur le sujet
d'accès au crédit de la part des
collectivités territoriales les froids
que la chose c'est plutôt stabilisé
après des passages plus difficiles dans
l'est dans les années antérieures on a
aujourd'hui certain équilibre entre
l'offre et la demande du secteur pour le
financement des collectivités
territoriales mais c'est un secteur qui
a abandonné poser des problèmes donc
l'avis du gouvernement est défavorable
sur cet amendement qui d'ailleurs vide
de sa substance le texte qui aurait pu
commencer par là
et qui évidemment
reprendraient si vous voulu aller au
fond l'ensemble des arguments qui sont
défendues depuis le début de l'autre à
vos de cet après midi
merci monsieur le ministre pour
explication de vote madame kuperman
oui je le président chez les messieurs
mes chers collègues je voterai bien
évidemment ces amendements et s'il
n'était pas adopté je ne voterai pas
comme un ensemble de mon groupe cet
article premier qui effectivement est au
coeur finalement de ce projet de loi je
crois que ça a été rappelé à plusieurs
reprises tout d'abord les considérations
du du conseil constitutionnel par
qui ont été annoncées fin décembre par
du conseil constitutionnel le principe
d'intériorité qui quand même pose d'une
façon plus générale
un problème délicat puisque vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure monsieur ministre
au sujet de l'intervention de madame
office qui revenait beaucoup sur
l'histoire mais le principe
d'antériorité
s'il est remis en question ne doit pas
permettre quand même d'oublier
l'histoire et de revenir dessus quand
cela peut être intéressant
quand aussi au principe d'intérêt
général je crois que ce sera au conseil
constitutionnel qui le dira il y aura y
at-il ou non justification au nom d'un
but d'intérêt général vous dites
vous-même monsieur mise depuis le début
finalement cette somme vous l'estimez
aux alentours des 10 7 milliards
peut-être plus puisse peut-être moins
j'ai envie de dire l'avenir le dira mais
c'est un peu facile aujourd'hui laissez
moi finir de nous annoncer une somme
dont finalement nous ne nous ne la
maîtrisons pas complètement de deux fait
parce que les procédures judiciaires
n'ont pas été jusqu'au bout parce qu'un
certain nombre de collectivités qui
pourraient être amenés à attaquer en
justice ne l'ont pas encore fait et donc
on est effectivement pour l'instant sur
un certain nombre de spéculations moi je
souhaite également revenir sur ce que
sur beaucoup de choses qu'on a entendues
serre que finalement ce ne sont pas les
collectivités qui ont créé les emprunts
toxiques et se sont pas elles qui sont
responsables aujourd'hui de ces emprunts
toxiques alors j'entends l'equilibre que
vous voulez que vous avez rappelez-vous
le gouvernement monsieur mise est
responsable du budget de l'état quand
vous parlez de réduire la dépense
publique c'est finalement uniquement au
niveau du budget de l'état mais in fine
et les collectivités les hôpitaux
publics
les office public hlm
tout cela c'est aussi de la dépense
publique et si les procédures en justice
doivent s'arrêter si elles ne sont plus
possibles
de par le principe d'antériorité de la
loi c'est bien in fine et cette dépense
publique certes qu'il n'y aura pas de
l'état mais d'autres qui sera de toutes
les façons à à mettre en oeuvre donc je
crois que pour moi pour simple
information sèche sur la commune un peu
moins de 9000 habitants commune d'unieux
dans la loire cote en 2012 la commune
après la décision de façon unilatérale
par le conseil municipal de ne pas payer
l'augmentation l'évolution des taux
d'intérêt auprès de dexia
c'était si nous avions payé l'équivalent
de 13 emplois municipaux
l'augmentation ou du déneigement pour
une saison de fort tonnage ou du
fonctionnement du périscolaire et
permettez moi il n'y avait pas à
l'époque la question des rythmes
scolaires qui étaient posées donc je
crois que ce sont des sommes
considérables des sommes considérables
effectivement qui doivent être prises en
compte beaucoup de ces collectivités et
ça a été rappelé dans un très bon
ouvrage
de dexia banque toxiques qui rappelle et
qui montre très bien comment
effectivement les agents nous dexia
faisait partie de la vie des élus avec
tout pleinement confiance et donc le
fait de dire aujourd'hui et de façon
rétroactive que ce n'est finalement pas
grave si les tg n'est pas inscrit c'est
finalement accepté le fait que ces
personnes là avec toute puissance sur
les élus et donc reconnaître le fait
qu'elles ont pu faire ce qu'elle
souhaitait faire signer y compris aux
élus locaux un certain nombre de prêts
dont il ne maîtrisait pas l'ensemble des
tenants et des aboutissants
ce qui est quand même là aussi un
problème puisque quand on ne connaît pas
l'ensemble des taux il ya quand même une
égalité entre celui qui fait signer et
celui qui perd a par la suite et donc je
ne pense pas en tout cas que au
ne votant pas ces amendements si c'est
ce que je te sens
sentir dans les différentes
interventions depuis ce début d'après
midi ou au contraire en votant cet
article premier que le sénat qui entend
défendre les collectivités locales et
les élus locales tiennent vraiment son
rôle parce que je crois qu'elles
attendent autre chose de nous
aujourd'hui que ce projet de loi merci
même que coeur mal monsieur collombat
bien le problème du manquement à l'état
de droit l'intrusion du législatif
j'aurais dire plutôt de l'exécutif dans
le judiciaire
ne semblant pas passionné ne semble pas
poser de problème je n'insisterai pas
pour inciter quand même sur deux points
qui me paraissent quand même plus que
problématique
moi ce qui me trouble c'est que le
traitement de faveur que le gouvernement
réserve aux organismes bancaires
à qu'elle
est à ce point incompressibles que à
quelques exceptions près on en a on les
a vécus tout à l'heure ces organismes
bancaires et dexia en tête ont failli à
leur à leur devoir de conseil
quelques courts passages du rapport de
la cour des comptes de 2011 en
définitive le succès des emprunts dits
structurés auprès des collectivités et
établissements publics locaux des
hôpitaux sans l'avoir avant tout dû à
une stratégie commerciale efficace des
établissements financiers centrée sur
des produits permettant de pacifier la
concurrence et de reconstituer des
marges les établissements de crédit qui
ont conçu ces produits et les
commercialise ne donne pas les
informations financières nécessaires à
la connaissance de leurs coûts d
information exagérément optimistes voire
erronées ont été données aux emprunteurs
leur garantissant une quasi absence de
risque ou bien que l'évolution de
l'index leur sera nécessairement
favorable la cour des comptes a quand
même pas l'habitude d'écrire ce genre de
généralités si ça ne procédait pas d'un
travail approfondi et en sanctionnant
l'absence de mention de taux effectif
global du taux de période la durée de
carrière etc le juge a considéré que ces
informations étaient nécessaires à
l'appréciation du coût réel finale parce
que c'est ça le problème le coût réel
finale des prêts bon mais comme la cour
des comptes et à la différence du
gouvernement et il a pas considéré qu'il
s'agissait d'une étourderie qu'il
s'agissait comme l'article 2 le laisse
entendre une faute vienne véniel mais
d'une faute essentiel c'est à dire une
absence d'information nécessaires pour
prendre pour prendre le risque alors le
gouvernement l'a dit se justifie en
prédisant bon rien moins que
une un risque pour l'économie et pour le
système bancaire
monsieur le ministre tout à l'heure vous
me disiez que c'était pas vrai j'ai là
l'étude d'impact
qui dit que enfin l'impact sur
l'économie française en cas d'absence de
validation ce conte 20 serait d'autant
plus important que le secteur bancaire
dans son ensemble connaîtra également
des pertes significatives
donc eh bien il va y avoir des problèmes
avec notre économie des problèmes avec
le système bancaire
donc et aussi avec la dégradation des
capacités
de lever des impôts des fonds de la caf
il des difficultés de financement du ce
des collectivités territoriales
elle-même ses dix ans tout en toutes
lettres
et pourquoi pas nous laisse-t-on
entendre un renforcement si ça se
passait pas comme ça un renforcement
donc de l'austérité budgétaire parce
qu'il faudrait bien pour faire plaisir à
bruxelles ben il faudrait bien quand
même qu'on fasse des économies des
économies ailleurs
autre point que je voudrais sur lequel
je voudrais revenir c'est les
estimations qui ont été faites 17 non
dit ça va coûter sarif de goûter 17
milliards vous me permettrez de ne pas
être complètement
on ne devait pas être complètement
convaincu de ces chiffres on nous donne
des différentes indications mais on sait
pas trop à quoi
à quoi ça peut correspondre moi ce qui
me semble le plus important
c'est les contreparties qu'il faudrait
verser aux banques de couverture c'est
ça le fond du c'est ça le fond du
problème et quand on regarde les coûts
en général c'est à peu près l'équivalent
ou les trois quarts du capital restant
dû alors si effectivement l'essentiel de
la solution du coût final de la sphère
dépend de ce qu'on va verser de ce qu'on
accepte de verser aux banques de
couverture aux banques de compensation
et bien c'est avec elle qu'il faut
négocier voire c'est elle qu'il faut
c'est elle qu'il faut traîner devant
devant la cour de justice devant les
tribunaux
poser la question est ce que les swaps
que vous avez convertis sont licites
or on a déjà des exemples je vous le
rappeler tout à l'heure comme la ville
de paris qui a demandé l'annulation d'un
swap donc de royal bank of scotland qui
a gagné bon en référé c'est pas sur le
fond enfin etc mais quand même le
tribunal a jugé que pour être pour être
licite une couverture d'un d'un contrat
renvoyé à la lucidité sideci dit et
pardon de ce contrat est-ce qu'on peut
garantir 100 comme ça un contrat qui ne
serait pas licite donc je crois que la
solution plutôt que de laisser les
choses en l'état plutôt que d'essayer de
de trouver une solution en empêchant la
poursuite donc des actions de justice et
bien c'est au contraire d'aller devant
les tribunaux ça me paraît être la
solution la plus équitable là - pourrait
sur le plan pratique laissons la justice
faire son travail
merci
pas d'autres explications de vote
je vais mettre aux voix ces deux
amendements le 1 d'abord qui est pour
c'est le même deux identiques
qui est content
qui s'abstient
ils ne sont pas adoptées
je mets donc au vote l'article 1er qui
et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté à l'article
2 1 à mende deux amendements identiques
un amendement numéro 2 qui est présentée
par monsieur collombat
je vous serai rapide puisque c'est le
plat suite de du précédent ce qui valait
pour lui vaut pour celui-là rock la
touche nouvelle avec cet article 2 c'est
nous dit l'exposé des motifs de mieux
proportionné les conséquences
financières d'une erreur de deux taux à
l'éventuelle du préjudice suivi par
l'emprunteur pour présenter comme une
erreur une stratégie de ventes
volontaires ce qui ressort clairement du
rapport de la cour des comptes que j'ai
cités pour le moins quand même un peu un
peu rapide et même si c'est le cas le
rôle du législateur est il de couvrir
les erreurs des banques aux frais de
leurs de leurs clients je ne le pense
pas ban qui par ailleurs ne manque pas
de collaborateurs qualifiés et par
ailleurs en général fort bien payé
encore une fois on se demande ce que le
gouvernement les experts ont pu faire
depuis 2008 pour que ce système
financier français en général et le
système de financement des collectivités
territoriales et du secteur public en
particulier restent à la merci
d'omissions d'erreur véniel ou de
jugement donc de tribunaux dans la dos
rédaction de documents contractuels dont
ils ont parfaitement l'habitude encore
une fois la meilleure solution dans
cette affaire qui n'a pas de bonne
solution mais la moins mauvaise en tout
cas me semble-t-il c'est de laisser la
justice décider de ce qui constitue ou
non une dissymétrie d'information
d'informations suffisantes pour
justifier pour sanctionner le prêteur ou
pour sanctionner donc le celui qui a
contracté le prêt voilà donc le sens de
cet amendement de suppression merci
monsieur caubin amendements identiques
qui est défendu par monsieur bouquet
oui monsieur le président chers
collègues cet article
l'un d'eux validation législative se
propose dans l'effet d'éviter la
prolifération de ce que l'on pourrait
appeler la jurisprudence
saint-maur-des-fossés puisque le motif
retenu pour la constituer fut celui du
taux effectif global erronée et par voie
de conséquence la stricte application du
taux d'intérêt légal ainsi donc
l'intérêt général serait dans le cas
précis après avoir tenté de priver les
collectivités locales du droit d'ester
en justice c'est le fondement du fonds
de soutien qui ne peut être mobilisée
qu'à raison du renoncement à toute
poursuite à l'encontre du créancier
présumé fautif de limiter les cas dans
lesquels le bon droit des mêmes
collectivités seraient respectés
l'impossibilité de défendre ses intérêts
est une violation du principe
constitutionnel de libre administration
et un exemple éclairant sur la
conception que certains se font parfois
de l'intérêt général
qu'avons nous d'ailleurs à y gagner le
rapport de l'étude d'impact qui vient
d'être cité parle avec une certaine
gravité d'un impact de 17 milliards
d'euros pour l'ensemble des dossiers
d'emprunts structurés qui nécessiterait
un provisionnement at on simplement
remarquer qu'en organisant les
conditions d'une forme d' amnistie
bancaire qui semble poser beaucoup moins
d'états d'âme d'ailleurs que l'amnistié
sociale des militants syndicaux dont il
fut question ici il ya quelques mois on
ne fait que déplacer une partie de la
charge ces fameux 17 milliards d'euros
du compte de l'état vers celui des
collectivités locales et que
structurellement au sens de nos
engagements européens
c'est exactement la même chose puisque
la dette publique comprend autant celle
de l'état que celle des collectivités
locales
la seule différence en dernière instance
c'est que l'un peu laissée relativement
courir son déficit budgétaire est
imputée d'ailleurs probablement ses 17
milliards à un déficit de à caractère
conjoncturel et que les autres sont
tenus de présenter des comptes à
l'équilibré tant en fonctionnement qu'en
investissement
la validation législative qui nous est
ici proposée est donc un pur transfert
de charge faisant de fait et de manière
indirecte participer selon cette
expression devenue fameuse à l'insu de
leur plein gré en quelque sorte les
collectivités locales à l'extinction de
dexia le problème c'est qu'un tel
transfert de charge n'a pas grand chose
à voir avec l'intérêt général est
beaucoup plus si l'on peut dire avec les
commodités d'une situation devenue par
ailleurs assez inconfortable pour l'état
un état dont nous savons pertinemment
qu'il est aujourd'hui engagé dans un
mouvement de réduction de son déficit
budgétaire pan structurelles que
conjoncturelles et qu'à partir de ce
postulat tous fait le compte pour
parvenir à l'objectif
l'intérêt général serait-il donc de
sacrifier la situation financière de
quelques communes endetté de plusieurs
hôpitaux dans l'incapacité aujourd'hui
de répondre aux attentes de leurs
patients deux syndicats et
l'établissement intercommunaux aux
ressources à sécher sur l'autel des
critères de convergence du traité
budgétaires européens tout cela pour
conduire à reconnaître irresponsables
les dirigeants d'une banque en faillite
et à laisser les financiers qui ont tiré
parti usé et abusé des éléments de
couverture des emprunts structurés
apprécier l'importance de leurs plus
values ci dessus évoqués
sur la porter
merci monsieur le président donc ces
deux amendements sont évidemment le
pendant de de l'article 1er est donc j'y
serais défavorable pour les mêmes motifs
je voudrais ajouter une chose j'ai n'ont
pas omis mais que j'ai pas signaler tout
à l'heure qui est qu'
il n'y a pas d'autorité de force jugé en
l'occurrence sinon il pourrait pas y
avoir de projet de loi de validation il
ya qu une décision de première instance
on ne sait pas quelle sera la décision
en appel et je rappelle que les
collectivités territoriales pourront
continuer à faire des recours sauf
évidemment sur le motif de l'absence de
théo g ou de théo g et rené voilà c'est
c'est c'est quand même quelque chose
c'est quand même quelque chose
d'important à signaler et quelles
conséquences ont dit non il y aura pas
de conséquences si parce que s'il n'y
avait pas cette cette loi de validation
immédiatement gelé dit tout à l'heure
évidemment c'est très technique mais les
commissaires aux comptes
demanderait que le risque financier soit
provisionner et c'est là on aurai je
vais dire en pratique la démonstration
de savoir quel est vraiment le risque en
tous les cas ce serait plusieurs
milliards qui devrait être
installé au bilan à la fois de dexia et
de l'asf il est si l'activité bancaire
de la suite était insuffisante pour
couvrir ce risque qui sera indiqué par
les par les commissaires aux comptes
faudrait ce moment là que l'état
intervienne et à ce moment là le rhum
dirait vous n'avez pas le droit
d'intervenir parce que nous avons
accepté la suite sous condition qu'elle
ait des activités bancaires normales
lors on peut considérer que c'est un
oukase intolérable de l'union européenne
il n'empêche que puisqu'on a aussi une
discussion en droit c'est l'état de
droit donc c'est la raison pour laquelle
je sens me référer à des exemples du
tour de france et cet exemple dangereuse
à l'issue de son plein gré quelles
qu'aient l'exécutif de collectivités
territoriales aurait accepté de se doper
financièrement je crois que c'est
impossible
merci monsieur rapportèrent monsieur le
ministre
mon argument dont je sens bien qu'il
convainque rompt pas
l'intégralité des
parlementaires ici présents mais on dit
les banques les banques
à tort ou à raison en 2008 un
gouvernement
a demandé au parlement
de finances et dexia de mémoire
j'étais jeune député la commission des
finances à l'assemblée nationale s'est
réuni en urgence
à la demande de madame lagarde alors
ministre
il nous a demandé d'accepter un
amendement de dernière minute d'un
milliard d'euros en nous disant sinon
demain c'est l'apocalypse
parallèlement de mémoire la caisse des
dépôts mettait deux milliards d'euros
dans dexia
2011 un autre gouvernement
décide que pour
mais c'est encore une fois on pourra
juger l'histoire un autre connaîtra la
fin de l'histoire
un autre gouvernement décide de
poursuivre l'aventuré en remettant peau
bon et puis nous nous retrouvons avec
la quasi totalité des emprunts détenu
par deux structures dexia ce fil
pardon où l'état est soit actionnaire
soient garantis
les autres actionnaires
bon c'est une situation que l'on
découvre encore des coups dont on hérite
ça a été dit tout à l'heure certes on
n'a pas découvert alors je ne verse pas
de larmes sur les dirigeants qui ont
conduit à cette situation
d'autres temps je me suis exprimé sur le
sujet
je ne verse pas de larmes sur les
collectivités qui aurait pu s'engager
sciemment dans une aventure dont elle
paye aujourd'hui les conséquences mais
j'ai du mal à faire le tri entre celles
qui ont été abusés et il y en a beaucoup
et entre celles qui on était pour
profiter d'une aubaine et qui
aujourd'hui s'en trouve marie et je ne
sais pas faire le tri et parfois même
les collectivités dont on part je
reviens sur la nuance entre la
collectivité et celui qui a pris un
moment la décision qui n'est pas
forcément celui aujourd'hui qui la
supportent et nous sommes devant un
risque vous mettez en doute
régulièrement le chiffre de 17 milliards
d'euros je répète je répète mais celui
jeu j'essaie de l'expliquer tout à
l'heure à la tribune
il y a le nombre d'organismes qui nous
disent que ce chiffre serait même
sous-estimé du moins une partie de ce
chiffre serait sous-estimer donc je ne
sais pas mais la prudence de la gestion
nous commande de dire à la
représentation à la représentation
nationale que voilà nous avons identifié
un risque que nous estimons à 17
milliards d'euros dont une partie est à
court terme une partie à un peu plus
long terme il se double d'un risque
systémique que certains aussi dénis et
que nous ne mettons un peu moins en
avant pour des raisons
je viens de présentation par rapport à
l'impérieuse nécessité
qui a été évoqué tout à l'heure
voilà la situation dans laquelle nous
nous trouvons il s'agit pas de dire nous
a mission nous sauvons les banques il
s'agit de dire il ya deux structures
dont nous savons que nous sommes engagés
pour autour de 17 milliards d'euros et
que si ça se passe mal c'est le budget
de l'état qui ne supportera voilà le
choix qui nous est posée ne sommes pas
là en train de sauver tel ou tel
dirigeant août est actionnaire de vente
ne nous sauvons si j'ose dire
parra donné la caricature du propos ne
nous sauvons nous mêmes
donc vous comprendrez que je suis
défavorable à cet amendement merci
monsieur le ministre monsieur collombat
pour explication de vote trois minutes
et moi je voudrais revenir sur sur trois
points d'abord le problème auquel nous
sommes confrontés en tout cas ce qui a
permis ce problème n'est pas née en 2008
2008 c'est l'aboutissement de tout un
ensemble de transformation etc ou
résolument d'alternance en alternance en
étal est toujours dans la même direction
parce que tout était bien tout était
beau regarder comme on peut financer
très facilement les collectivités
territoriales et s'est
mis beaucoup mieux qu'avec votre système
vétuste et c'est bien donc de sur ce
plan-là je pense que les responsabilités
malheureusement sont bien partagées
deuxièmement ce qui me frappe c'est
c'est ce discours comme s'il y avait une
mécanique complètement implacable contre
laquelle on ne peut rien c'est comme ça
vous êtes vous monsieur le ministre on
ne peut qu' on ne peut que se soumettre
parce que les experts financiers
d'ailleurs ceux qui sont à l'origine
intellectuelle de ce système nous disent
que ben vous pouvez pas vous êtes obligé
à provisionner enfin et c'était un bon
voilà bien ou pas ce que parce que c'est
bruxelles on a des accords avec
bruxelles c'est ma troisième remarque je
constate que l'état de droit il est
quand même parfois un peu de travers
parce que quand il s'agit de revenir de
changer la loi de changer la loi pour
que
pour que on minimise les pertes des
organismes financiers
et là en l'occurrence plein qui a été
nationalisé quasiment en tout cas où
l'état est majoritaire on n'a pas
tellement d'états d'âme par contre
s'agissant s'agissant de résister à cet
enchaînement résister donc à 7 à cette
mécanique implacable la banon peut pas
faire autrement il n'y a pas d'autre il
n'y a pas il n'y a pas d'autre solution
bon je trouve ça quand même un petit peu
un petit peu fort et l'impression qui
domine c'est effectivement ça on n'a pas
d'autre solution et c'est toujours du
même côté que que les choses vont et
bien on va essayer de faire en sorte que
les systèmes bancaires subissent le
moins de pertes possibles dans cette
affaire les collectivités ma foi elles
elles subiront elles ont l'habitude
madame beaufils
quelques remarques
par rapport à la discussion sur
sur cette demande de suppression
lorsque nous posons les questions comme
on les pose aujourd'hui on le pose parce
que bon la situation se pose est pour
beaucoup
aujourd'hui par rapport aux conséquences
de la pratique de dexia mais je rappelle
que dexia n'était pas la seule banque à
faire des emprunts structurés
je rappelle aussi j'ai dit dans mon
propos tout à l'heure qu'un certain
nombre d'autres pays européens ont été
confrontés à ce même type de problème et
je voudrais revenir sur cet aspect parce
que c'est bien une conception
du système qui aujourd'hui
nous pose le problème auquel on est
confronté
et ce système il est porté aussi par la
conception de la construction européenne
est posée que je disais tout à l'heure
que ce que la l'europe par la bce a
accepté de faire en direction du système
bancaire moi je me pose la question
pourquoi lorsqu'il s'agit des prêts aux
collectivités territoriales nous ne
pourrions pas avoir aussi une
sollicitation d'accompagnement de la
résolution du problème par
l'intermédiaire de la bce dont on sait
très bien que ces cas pas cité
d'accompagnement du secteur bancaire et
à une condition financière bien plus
favorable que celle que bien souvent on
nous présente pour la renégociation des
prêts structurés aujourd'hui en nous
disant il faut aller chercher sur le
marché des prêts pour renégocier les
prêts que nous vous avions fait dans des
conditions qui font qu'elle nous coûte
très cher parce que c'est ça ce que vous
nous comptabilisés par rapport aux 17
milliards sait les conditions dans
lesquelles la suisse est un est obligé
d'aller rechercher du financement sur
les marchés financiers ben oui en partie
j'entends bien monsieur le ministre mais
c'est quand même une des raisons qui
nous est posée et pour quelle raison ne
pourrions nous pas solliciter la
capacité de prêts de la bce pour nous
permettre que ces négociations se
fassent dans d'autres conditions que
celles qui sont prêtes aujourd'hui c'est
un vrai sujet que j'ai abordé dans mon
intervention général et à laquelle pour
le moment on ne répond pas et c'est
pourquoi nous ne sommes pas partisans de
ce texte tel qu'il nous est proposé
aujourd'hui
merci même beau fils je vais mettre aux
voix ces deux amendements
qui et pour
qui et contre
qui s'obtient
ils ne sont pas adoptées je mets aux
voix l'article 2 qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté l'article 3 même vote vote après
l'article 3 un amant cet amendement
n'est pas défendu tombe
l'article 3 bis même vote que le 3
après l'article 3 bis un amendement
ni en 3 qui est présentée par monsieur
collomb bas
m
donc
c'est une annexe 10 secondes
du projet le délai de prescription donc
en matière civile étant de cinq ans à
compter du jour le titulaire d'un droit
a connu aurait dû connaître les faits
lui permettant d'exercer un recours il
s'agit d'éviter qu'en s'éternisant les
négociations entre emprunteurs et
organismes financiers interdisent tout
recours contentieux en cas d'échec
puisque en fait tout va dépendre de la
capacité ou non à trouver un accord pour
sortir des impasses dans laquelle on est
merci monsieur comme obama sur la porter
je ne suis pas favorable à cet
amendement parce que peuvent pas pour
deux raisons d'abord parce que dans le
cas de la de la législation actuelle les
collectivités locales ont signé des à
des avenants
assez à ses contrats de prêts 2008 2009
2010 et que la prescription quinquennale
et suffisante deuxième manche j'ajoute
que pour la raison qui va reste enfin
pour le motif qui va rester aux
collectivités de deux territoriale
d'engager la responsabilité de
l'organisme bancaire sur la sur la base
finalement du conseil ou du défaut de
conseil la prescription quinquennale
n'existe
merci monsieur l'appartement se
munissent
même avis même avis
pas d'explications de vote je le mets
aux voix qui est pour
le numéro trois qui étaient présentés
par monsieur coulombe à
qui et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adoptée
après l'article 3 bis un amendement
numéro 6 qui est présentée par monsieur
de la et oui monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
il s'agit d'un amendement qui est qui a
pour objet de d'essayer d'avoir
annuellement un rapport qui fasse le
point complet sur la situation de la
recherche équilibré d'une solution qui
nous est proposé aujourd'hui par le
gouvernement et l'idée sais je sais
qu'il ya déjà un certain nombre de
rapports qui existent
mais moi je trouve qu'il serait
intéressant d'avoir un rapport complet à
la fois sur la situation des
collectivités sur l'utilisation du fonds
de soutien et aussi sur la situation de
dexia et des différents prêteurs qui ont
aussi leur part de responsabilité
ça me donne l'occasion aussi de demander
à monsieur le ministre si on pourrait
avoir des nouvelles un peu du sort des
dirigeants de dexia qui avait bénéficié
à leur départ de cette institution de
primer et de montants assez élevée moi
je me souviens de 600 ou 700 mille euros
et j'aimerais savoir ce que sont devenus
puisque ses dirigeants étaient a priori
des hauts fonctionnaires dont ils ont
sans doute récupérer des postes dans
leur ancienne administration et
j'aimerais savoir ce que sont devenus
ces primes est ce que l ont été
récupérés ou pas donc d'une question que
je pose que j'avais déjà posé à l'époque
et voilà en tout cas il me semble qu'il
serait intéressant par rapport au débat
que nous avons aujourd'hui et et à la
difficulté de de ce la question que nous
traitons aujourd'hui de pouvoir avoir un
rapport qui fait une analyse complète de
la situation chaque année et que ce
rapport fasse l'objet d'un débat lors
j'ai mis la remise de ce rapport peut
faire l'objet d'un débat d'une
déclaration en séance publique moi je
mettrais même que doit faire l'objet
devrait faire l'objet en tout cas de
d'un débat chaque année sur la situation
à la fois des collectivités des prêteurs
et puis de dexia et de l'engagement de
l'état bon je vous remercie monsieur
prix merci monsieur de l'est sont à
porter
et c'est le président donc
la demande de notre collègue est
satisfaite
juridiquement puisque comment dire
l'article 32 de la loi bancaire prévoit
des rapports qu'ils
signalent qu'ils demandent
l'article 4 de la loi de finances
rectificative que nos ventes 2011
prévoit de faire un rapport sur la
situation financière de dexia et enfin
l'activité du fonds de soutien il est
prévu à l'article 92 de la loi de
finances pour 2014 qu'il y ait un
rapport donc juridiquement si je puis
dire votre demande est satisfaite mais
on se sera plutôt une demande de report
de retrait parce que je pense que
notamment monsieur le ministre pourra
nous dire que si ces rapports n'ont pas
été
déposés ce qui est regrettable pour
l'information du parlement ça n'est
qu'une question de temps
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre
on a déjà fait état du rapport relatif
à l'article 30 de la loi bancaire
jeu j'ajoute que le comité d'orientation
et de suivi prévue par
la loi de finances 2014 est lui aussi
chargé de publier je cite un rapport
annuel remis au gouvernement et au
parlement sur les aides versées
enfin une information détaillée fournie
sur la mise en oeuvre la garantie à
accorder à dexia dans le cadre du
rapport annuel de performance
le rap de la mission budgétaire
engagement financier de l'état une
section de la nex du compte général de
l'état est d'ailleurs consacrée au suivi
du plan de soutien à dexia donc je pense
que ce sénateur votre souci sur ce point
est parfaitement satisfaits je vous
remercie de vouloir prendre des
nouvelles des dirigeants de dexia je
pense qu'ils y seront sensibles à
ma connaissance
quand on dirait les analyses juridiques
qui ont été faites par mes prédécesseurs
où j'allais dire mes prédécesseurs pas
forcément les deux derniers mais ceux
d'avant ont montré qu'il était assez
difficile de revenir sur les facilités
la version
qui m'a été fournie à l'époque quand
j'étais parlementaire que les conditions
juridiques des contrats qui prévoyait ce
à quoi vous avez fait allusion était
difficilement contestable et on me dit
là mais je pourrais à l'occasion
vérifier qu'il semblerait que des
analyses se confirme
merci monsieur le ministre
les explications de vote de la
messe le président monsieur le ministre
je prends bonne note de ce qui vient
d'être dit les dernières nouvelles sur
les dirigeants je m'inquiétais pas trop
de leur sort vous aviez bien compris je
souhaiterais simplement m'assurer que
l'état actionnaire ne renouvelle pas ce
genre de contrat surtout
pour des situations dans lesquelles on
peut quand même penser que la gestion
n'a pas été parfaite loin de là et que
la situation dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons aujourd'hui qui nécessite de
faire des acrobaties pour éviter de
supporter des milliards d'euros de
pertes je pense que les dirigeants
devraient clairement supporter un
minimum de conséquence et je n'ai pas du
tout l'impression que ça soit le cas
donc j'espère que les contrats des
futurs dirigeants de deux sociétés dont
l'état est actionnaire seront un petit
peu regarder d'un peu plus près
dorénavant je souhaite en tout cas et
pour ce qui est des rapports bah écoutez
moi je prends note effectivement je le
savais un petit peu que j'avais un
certain nombre de rapports qui avaient
déjà été prévues en l'occurrence si on
peut en faire une certaine compilation
et une certaine synthèse de façon à nous
montrer une vision complète de la
situation à la fois comme je le disais
tout à l'heure pour les collectivités
pour les institutions financières et
pour l'état ce serait une bonne chose en
tout cas pour nous parlementaires ça
nous permettrait de voir clair sur ce
dossier assez compliqué en tout cas bon
comme le demande monsieur le ministre je
vais retirer et le rapporteur je vais
retirer donc mon amendement merci
monsieur de là mais monsieur le ministre
vous répondre je crois
je voulais je voulais simplement précisé
que le gouvernement français a demandé
et obtenu une baisse des dirigeants
actuels de la rémunération des
dirigeants actuels de dexia suite à des
informations je crois qu'il y avait
choqué à juste titre beaucoup de monde
merci monsieur ministre
alors intitulé du projet de loi un
amendement numéro 4 présentée par
monsieur collomb bas
n'aura échappé à personne c'est un
amendement de provocation
mais j'aime bien que les choses seraient
dit
j'aime bien que les choses ce n'est pas
ce que c'est de ça dont il s'agit c'est
une amnistie pour
des des contractants qui n'ont pas
satisfait donc
donc je pense que c'est plus clair alors
il ya des raisons nous a expliqué
d'intérêt général très bien ben ma foi
ça a été plaidée brillamment aujourd'hui
et je ne fais pas de souci pour l'issue
pour l'issue du vote m'enfin
faut pas non plus s'étonner si nos
électeurs ont de plus en plus de mal à
comprendre pas s'étonner trop alors
disons les choses comme elles sont je
propose en tout cas que de dire de dire
la vérité et puis tu expliquer pourquoi
puisque apparemment on peut pas faire
autrement enfin moi j'en suis pas
persuadé mais ceux qui défendent le
projet en sont persuadés on ne peut pas
faire autrement on est on est là pieds
et poings liés c'est pas la peine de
d'avoir des titres ronflants qui ne
correspondent pas du tout à la réalité
et aux intentions
merci monsieur collombat sur la porter
monsieur le président je suis
défavorable à cet amendement qui reflète
la subjectivité d'appréciation de son
auteur
merci monsieur important monsieur le
ministre
non mais je crois qu'il s'agit du
dernier amendement donc je suis
peut-être en profiter pour
saluer la qualité des débats
sur un sujet dont on a dit qu'il était
difficile complexe on a commencé par là
nous pensons avoir présenté un texte
équilibré d'autres ont une appréciation
différente ça peut être légitime
et je terminais simplement pour donner
mon avis sur la maintenant en disant que
le gouvernement ne cède pas à la
provocation
merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur bouquet pour l'explication de
vote
oui un mot de commentaires en réaction
cet amical provocation qui peut pas nous
laisser insensible sur le mot amnistie
bon c'est un mot qui chatouille un peu
qui agace peut-être qui choque parfois
mais je citerai ici un article de la
gazette des communes
qui a révélé un rapport confidentiel de
l'inspecteur général des finances rédigé
en juin 2012 pour évaluer les risques
financiers pesant sur une reprise de la
filiale dexma d'un dexia municipal
agency il fixe la politique à tenir pour
l'état à partir d'une vision de la
réalité que d'aucuns trouvaient très
discutable ce rapport impute sans aucune
audition préalable ni aucune étude de
cas argumenté la responsabilité de la
situation aux collectivités concernées
et absout aussi bien dexia que
l'ensemble des autorités de tutelle et
de contrôler cela a été dit il fait
litière des rapports antérieurs de la
cour des comptes comme de la commission
d' enquête parlementaire il se il passe
également sous silence les jugement déjà
rendu par plusieurs tribunaux en faveur
de certaines collectivités fin de
citation donc absolution pour les
banques pénitence pour les collectivités
pécheresse mes chers collègues le débat
montre bien que les collectivités en
france n'ont pas échappé aux folles
dérives de la finance mondiale
notre groupe pense que les
responsabilités principales et nous
l'avons dit sont à chercher
essentiellement du coup tel
établissement de crédit et quand ta
bouche et vous vend de la viande avariée
faut-il chercher la responsabilité du
client intoxiqués
merci monsieur
luc hermann
oui moi je suis le président finisse mes
chers collègues je crois qu'au delà de
la provocation en tout cas cela résume
finalement à travers cette proposition
d'amendement comment le texte est perçu
par un certain nombre d'élus locaux
de tous bords confronté aujourd'hui à la
gestion et au devenir finalement de
leurs collectivités qui ont contracté
des emprunts structurés
quelles que soient les conditions dans
lesquelles d'ailleurs ceux-ci ont été
contractés mais en tout cas qu'il
appartient aujourd'hui de devoir prendre
en compte et puis je crois que nous
avons à travers notre amendement numéro
this fait également un certain nombre de
propositions pour permettre à mieux et
plus à perdre que les banques mieux et
plus contribuer à cet effort de de prise
en compte de la difficulté auquel sont
confrontés aujourd'hui les collectivités
locales hôpitaux et office public hlm
cela n'a pas été retenu je le regrette
mais in fine est à la fin de cette
discussion voilà bond et alice sont
exprimés mais on reste quand même un
petit peu sur ce sentiment que l'on a
plutôt
tendance à excuser les banques qu à les
sanctionner d'autant que à travers le
débat que nous avons eu je reste peu
convaincus de l'argument qui a été
évoqué sur le fait que finalement il y à
il y a et c'est une réalité plusieurs
catégories de collectivités celles qui
ont sciemment celles qui n'ont pas
sciemment et comment juger mais nous
savons toutes et tous ici la grande
majorité des collectivités qui
aujourd'hui sont concernés par cette
question ne l'ont pas fait sciemment et
donc on se renvoie un débat finalement
qui au nom de quelques-uns qui ont fait
sciemment cette chose et que peut-être
il faudrait d'ailleurs voir et peut-être
ces cinq lois qu'il aurait fallu faire
comment condamner ceux qui sciemment ont
mis en péril les politiques menées pour
leurs concitoyens les habitants de leurs
collectivités territoriales et eux les
juger et le condamner en tant que telle
plutôt que finalement de mettre tout le
monde dans le même paquet parce que
comme il y en a quelques-uns qui met
tout le monde tout le monde paye ça me
rappelle un petit peu a observé les
débats quand j'étais élu étudiante on ne
peut pas mettre la gratuité des études
parce que sinon c'est ou de la sécurité
sociale étudiante parce que sinon
certains pourrait zur paix le statut
pour pouvoir contourner le cadre et
bénéficié d' avantages auxquels ils
n'auraient pas le droit donc au final
comme quelques-uns pourrait contourner
et bien on ne prend pas les mesures qui
peuvent arranger le plus grand monde je
crois que effectivement bon nous
connaissons tous notre collègue ça se
veut certainement un petit peu
provocateur mais je pense en tout cas
très révélateur de comment ce texte in
fine et risquent d'être ressentie par
les élus locaux les administrateurs d
office public hlm et des hôpitaux
merci
bien je mets aux voix cet amendement qui
et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté mes
chers collègues je vais mettre aux voix
l'ensemble du projet de loi y at il des
demandes d'explications de vote monsieur
collombat
vous voudrez bien m'excuser si
vous semble un peu répétitif mais enfin
c'est là c'est la conclusion fait un
petit résumé demande au dessus des
arguments que nous avons essayé de
développer
bon sens rencontrer grand écho j'en
conviens volontiers mais je pense que
on se reverra
on se reverra sur ce sujet là on se
reverra sur ce sujet là parce que je
suis pas bien persuadé que je suis
absolument pas persuadé que la méthode
qui consiste au cas par cas à et couper
la barque qui prend l'eau soit soit soit
la bonne je pense qu'il faudrait
peut-être un jour se décider à prendre
des mesures qui soient un peu plus
radicale
c'est normal puisque je suis d'un groupe
du rdse
alors ne pas voter ce projet de loi nous
dit le gouvernement se serait exposé le
pays en général les collectivités
territoriales en particulier à des
difficultés de grande ampleur alors la
première question on l'a évoqué
plusieurs fois c'est évidemment qui est
responsable de cette situation
je ne reviendrai pas gelé développer à
la fois ceux qui ont laissé s'installer
ce système et perdurer un suspect un
système une telle vulnérabilité encore
une fois que
quelques jugements de tg peuvent peuvent
le mettre en péril et en particulier je
trouve quand même un peu fort que le
système qui a été mis en place sur les
ruines de dexia pour le financement des
collectivités territoriales soit aussi
vulnérables à ce genre d'aléas que le
précédent enfin quelle idée d'aller
loger les les bombes à entendre les
emprunts toxiques les actifs toxiques de
dexia dans le nouveau système alors
évidemment là on se trouve en position
de faiblesse en position disons de
d'otages 1 par rapport donc au système
au système financier moi ce qui me ce
qui me fascine et ce qui m'interroge
c'est que on
continue après tout ce qu'on sait à
développer les mêmes les mêmes arguments
responsable de la situation
aussi évidemment on l'a dit les
organismes les organismes financiers
beaucoup plus je n'insisterai pas que
les collectivités locales même si ici ou
là on peut effectivement relevé d
attitude un peu bizarre j'ai cité les
prédécesseurs de de mon collègue qui est
assez célèbre c'est vrai qu'il ya eu des
abus quand même d'aider des
comportements qui sont qui sont tout
simplement ils sont tout simplement
répréhensible mais quand même si on sent
trahie si on s'en tient à ce que dit la
cour des comptes si on s'en tient à un
jugement qui ont été rendus quand même
dans cette affaire il ya eu sinon
dissimulation volontaire du moins
absence donc d'informations suffisantes
pour se faire une idée sur ce coup ce
que coûteront secoue coûterait en
définitive donc les les endroits
merveilleux les prêts merveilleux que
dexia et les autres disent distribués
mais qui précisément est le mieux placé
pour
trancher pour savoir qui est responsable
et à kehl à quel degré eh bien j'ai
toujours la faiblesse de penser que
c'est le juge qui pourra dire si
effectivement dans de tels cas c'est
plutôt la collectivité ou plutôt
l'organisme bancaire or le but
finalement vous delà du projet le globe
c'est clairement de mettre à l'abri les
banques de tout de toute responsabilité
bon contre contre une participation
enfin une participation modeste 50
millions tout à l'heure notre collègue
rappelait les bénéfices sur une année de
la plus grande banque pour dire comme
ses actifs ces 2000 2008 milliard de
fois c'est pas beaucoup un finalement
enfin ça représente quand même les seuls
colossal par rapport à ces malheureux 50
millions alors
je pense aussi que ce projet de loi va à
l'encontre de ce qui en principe est
recherché c'est à dire qu'on arrive à
trouver des accords parce que si on
désarme l'un des partenaires est bien il
n'y a pas beaucoup de chances qu'eux
l'autre c'est nous du moins disons soit
soit accommodant et je n'y reviendrai
pas on a dit que dans la sphère
finalement de le dexia lâche il est le
états n'ont pas été parmi les pas les
partenaires les plus les plus
accommodants mais je dirais que ce qui
personnellement me gêne le plus dans
cette affaire c'est l'absence de
résistance au pouvoir financier du
pouvoir politique ce gouvernement comme
des prédécesseurs comme si pour
reprendre la formule d'une célèbre
social-démocrate cerise nos alternatives
je croyais
j'aurais failli citer un autre social
démocrate qui dit la finance à ce combat
mais c'était l'autre c'était il ya
longtemps alors en espèces en l'espèce
plutôt que de nous appuyer sur la
justice ce qui est un minimum comme je
les dis pour des états de droit et comme
le font d'ailleurs d'autres états qui
sont quand même peu soupçonnable de
socialisme je pense aux usa par exemple
qui ont négocié chèrement leur
renoncement à poursuivre dans la sphère
des subprimes 86 milliard de dollars de
désistement entre 2 2 points de pénalité
mais en tout cas quasi pénalités entre
2010 et 2013 pour qu'ils retirent leur
pour qu'ils retirent leur plainte ou qui
laissent pleuvoir vous en voyez tous les
jours où tous les jours et semaines
donc il s pleuvoir des des milliards de
dollars d'amande sur ce qu'ils appellent
eux les banksters
alors ce que je regrette le plus c'est
que on n'anticipe pas on subit alors on
nous abritons parce que on pense qu'on
ne peut pas faire autrement parce qu' à
bruxelles alors c'est parce que
précisément je ne me résous pas à cela
que je voterai contre ce projet de loi
s'il ce combat madame beaufils
et monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre chers collègues nous avons déjà
largement débattu des sujets abordés
mais je voudrais
quand même dire que on aurait pu penser
que la décision prise par le conseil
constitutionnel
suite à la loi de finances aurait pu
nous permettre d'accélérer le décret
relatif aux nouvelles règles de
négociation de renégociation des
emprunts structurés des collectivités
territoriales et je crois que les
retards pris par la publication
nous amène quand même à douter de la
bonne volonté du secteur bancaire de
faire en sorte que les négociations se
passent dans de très bonnes conditions
je voudrais également dire que pour nous
et ne peut pas être acceptable de
considérer que
quelque part on amnistie parce que je
pense que le terme même si notre
collègue disais tout à l'heure que
c'était de la provocation c'est quand
même quelque part une amnistie
de la pratique bancaire qui a été
celle que l'on a connue tout ces
dernières années
elle ne peut pas être acceptable elle ne
peut pas être admise elle n'est pas
admissible
dans ce domaine et je pense que
véritablement il faut en effet que
nous en terme en tant que parlementaire
l'ensemble du monde politique
rappelle au secteur bancaire le rôle
important qu'ils jouent dans dans la vie
économique de notre pays et comment son
rôle vis-à-vis des collectivités
territoriales doit être beaucoup plus
responsable qu'il l'ont qui ne l'a été
dans cette dernière période je voudrais
dire aussi que ce texte ça a été dit
pourrait très bien se traduire
si les négociations ne se passe pas
mieux qu'elle ne se passe actuellement
si les renégociations ne se passe pas
mieux qu'elles se passent actuellement
par des nouveaux contentieux qui ferait
que l'état qui est appelé en garantie en
effet comme vous l'avez rappelé se
retrouvant plus grande difficulté qu'il
n'est aujourd'hui par rapport à la
situation donc je pense que
véritablement cette loi ne résout aucun
des problèmes face auxquels on est
confrontés par rapport à l'endettement
des collectivités territoriales et il
nous faut véritablement réfléchir
autrement la question j'ai soulevé
quelques questions tout à l'heure dans
mon intervention lors
de la discussion générale comme je
l'avais fait dans dans d'autres
interventions je crois qu'il faut
véritablement traité autrement c'est ces
contentieux qui existe aujourd'hui si on
veut se sortir de la difficulté mais je
ne pense pas que l'étape être
je dire en situation de considérer que
c'est son intérêt général que l'on doit
avoir
dans dans ce texte de loi l'intérêt
général des collectivités ne peut pas
être mis de côté
pour défendre l'intérêt général de
l'état c'est en tout cas la façon dont
ça a été présentée jusqu'à maintenant et
nous ne pouvons approuver cela il faut
que les deux soient véritablement partie
prenante de la réflexion en permanence
dans un texte quel qu'il soit donc je
souhaite qu'on réfléchisse autrement
c'est pourquoi nous vous invitons donc à
voter contre contre ce texte de loi et
nous avons demandé un scrutin public
pour ce faire mais aussi un beau fils me
demanderez
oui monsieur président brièvement j'ai
déjà la tribune expliqué que les
socialistes voteront sept projets et
soutiendront la proposition du
gouvernement mais permettez moi de
saluer les élus qui ont été confrontés à
ses difficultés
si l'on regarde parmi les nombreuses
collectivités celle qui émaillent notre
territoire les 36000 communes plus les
départements les régions
convenons que ces élus qui sont trouvés
en difficulté qui sont en difficulté
aurait plutôt ici un soutien et un appui
avec la sfi le désir de préserver les
fils et malgré tout ce qu'ils ont pu
vivre je pense à notre collègue de
saint-etienne qui a trouvé cette
situation qui a vécu quelques années
avec les difficultés qu'il a eu à vivre
et d'autrui et saluons les présidents
claude bartolone de seine-saint-denis
qui ont trouvé une situation telle et
qui ont dû vivre avec qui ont dû en
pâtir beaucoup y compris en expliquant à
leurs citoyens et combien la situation
était difficile mais je voudrais saluer
permettait le peut-être pour un petit
moment d'optimisme en cette fin de
soirée tous les élus qui sollicité par
les mêmes
systèmes bancaires agressif dont nous
avons parlé ont fait des analyses ont
fait faire des analyses et ont su dire
non un contrat ça se fait à deux
nombreux mois je connais certains
présidents de départements qui
sollicitait on dit que ce contrat-là
cette condition là ne leur paraissait
pas tout à fait prudente et qui donc ils
y ont renoncé voilà donc nous avons sans
doute vrai cet après midi pour la
protection la plus efficace possible le
rapporteur a salué l'aspect équilibré et
nous avons je pense dans les dispositifs
adoptés plus récemment dans d'autres
dispositions que ce soit la loire
métropole où la réforme la loi bancaire
nous avons fait en sorte que tout cela
ne puisse pas se reproduire mais
finalement au nom de la libre
administration des collectivités
sans doute faut-il recommander à nos
collègues lorsqu'ils sont confrontés à
des offres parfois mirifiques d'être
prudents dans leurs analyses et le
savoir parfois dire non c'est en tout
cas ce que je souhaite et j'espère que
ceux qui sont confrontés aux difficultés
trouveront les issues positives merci
merci madame andrée
bien chers collègues
il ya plus d'explications de vote j'ai
été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe crc sur l'ensemble
du projet de loi il va donc être procédé
on scrute un public dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 de notre
règlement le scrutin sera ouvert dans
quelques instants
le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos
il
bien chers collègues résultats du
scrutin numéro 176 sur l'ensemble du
projet de loi relatif à la sécurisation
des contrats de prêts structurés
souscrits par les personnes morales de
droit public
nombre de votants 342 nombre de
suffrages exprimés
186 pour l'adoption 138 contre
l'adoption 48 le sénat a adopté
voilà comme vous avez pu le voir à
l'issue d'une séance plutôt mouvementée
les sénateurs ont finalement adopté ce
projet de loi sur les emprunts toxiques
il ya eu de nombreux abstention
notamment au groupe ump vous l'avez
entendu a notamment à travers la sortie
finale de pierre yves collombat certains
élus estiment que les collectivités
locales sans véritablement floués dans
ce projet de loi vous pouvez toujours
voir et revoir toutes les séances sur
notre site sur publicsenat.fr prochain
rendez vous de l'actualité parlementaire
cet après midi à 16h30 pour 24 heures
sénat avec deux auditions celle de
pierre rené lemas puis celle de ségolène
royal très bonne fin de journée sur les
chaînes parlementaires